[Musique]
ça nous concerne tous parce que on aura
tous l'occasion d'être peut-être âgées
c'est sûr d'être dépendant peut-être
moins sûr on aura tous occasion en tout
cas de d'avoir ou de la famille ou des
parents ou des des proches qui auront
besoin d'une aide à la fois médicale et
au niveau d'indépendance pour finir leur
vie leurs jours il faudra créer en
moyenne 50 à 60 mille places nouvelles
dans les ehpad pour permettre
d'accueillir toutes les personnes qui en
auront besoin on demande à encadrer à
contrôler et à sanctionner les estiot
nerfs qui ne rempliraient pas leurs
devoirs d'utilisation à bon escient de
des deniers publics
on ne peut plus contraints de se
contenter de contrôler les
établissements individuellement mais il
faut contrôler les groupes donc il faut
mettre en place un contrôle sur plan
national ce qui n'existait pas
aujourd'hui et puis il faut peut-être
limiter l'expansion de ces groupes et
donner un peu plus de moyens au niveau
des du public et puis globalement il
faudra donner plus de moyens à tous les
établissements parce que la qualité dans
les établissements
si elle est insuffisante c'est aussi par
manque de moyens en personnel et qu'il
faudra les aider dans ce domaine
[Musique]